you know what's amazing is how many of
the Soviet scientists contributed to so
much of what we understand today and
they were completely in hiding like
there's no Google they couldn't look up
on scholar they had nothing they had to
wait for journals to get approved by the
Communist Party to get approved and then
and then and only then if they weren't a
member of some class I'm sure you know
like Jewish scientists you had a
passport I said Jew on your passport
yeah and zeldovic the famous uh yaakov
uh zeldovic he was the advisor one of my
advisors Alexander palmarev um and he
had to only because he was like at a
noble level and you know was one of the
fathers of the Soviet atomic bomb
program could he even get his Jewish
student he was Jewish too but but only
by virtue of his standing of his
intellectual accomplishments would they
give him the dispensation to let his
student you know travel to Georgia or
something and it makes What We complain
about and I complain about Academia and
it's like oh well what can I talk about
we have no idea of how good it is and
that they were able to create things
like inflation completely isolated from
the West I mean some of these people
wouldn't didn't meet like people like
Stephen Hawking until you know he was
almost dead uh and they just learned
this thing through smuggled in you know
it's it's a work of heroism especially
in cosmology there's so many
cosmologists that worked incredibly hard
probably because they were working the
they could they could pass off as well
we're doing stuff for the atomic bomb
program as well which they were at the
same time there is uh interesting uh
incentives in the Soviet system that
maybe we can take this tangent uh for a
brief moment
that uh because there's a dictatorship
authoritarian regime throughout the the
history of the 20th century for the
Soviet Union
science was prioritized and because the
state prioritized it to the propaganda
Machines of the news and so on it
actually was really cool to be a
scientist like you were highly valued in
society maybe that's a better way to say
it and I I would say you're saying like
we have it easy now in that sense it was
kind of uh beneficial to be a scientist
in that Society because you were seen as
a hero as there's there's no ageless
hero of the Soviet Republic and that you
know there's positives to that I mean
I'm not saying I would take their the
networks or the positives but it is
interesting to see a world in which
science was highly prized in
um in a capitalist system or maybe not
capitalists let's just say the American
system the celebrities are the uh the
athletes the actors and actresses maybe
Business Leaders musicians uh and you
know the people who elect are sort of
lawyers and
lawyers
so it's interesting to think of a world
where science was highly prized but they
had to do that science
within the constraints of always having
big brother watching it's uh yeah the
same in Germany Germany had you know
highly prized I mean one of the most
famous tragic to Me cases is Fritz Haber
who invented the you know Haber Bosh
process that allowed us to I don't know
have you eaten yet you look he looks I
mean I know you fast intermittent fast
every day and you do that you know I
said cleb and you got it's a little
drool but he says I'm lifting and I look
slim this is amazing I'm gonna clip this
out and put it on Tinder I think that's
a website you gotta go swipe left or
right for that I don't know
um but when you think about like you
know what he did and created the
fertilizer process that we all enjoy and
we eat from every day
um he was a German nationalist first and
foremost even though he was a Jew and he
personally went to witness the
application of ammonia chlorine gas
applied during trench warfare in 1916 in
battles in Brussels and whatever and he
was they had a whole conjure of Nobel
laureates and chemistry and physics you
know that would go and witness these
atrocities but that was also they were
they were almost putting science above I
don't want to say human dignity but but
of like who the fact that he would later
be suppressed and actually some of his
um relatives would die in Auschwitz
because of the chemical that he invented
also called zycon B and so it's just
it's just unbelievable so I I feel like
that does have resonance today in this
worship of of science you know and
listen to science and follow the science
which is more like scientism
um and there is still a danger you know
I always say
um just because you're an atheist
doesn't mean you don't have a religion
you know just because you you know in my
case in in my books I I talk a lot about
the Nobel Prize it's kind of like a
kosher Idol it's something that you can
worship you know it doesn't do any harm
and and we want those people that are so
significant in their intellectual
accomplishments because there is a core
of America and the Western World in
general that does worship and really
look at science predominantly because it
gives us technology
um but there's something really cool
about that and so for me it's hard to
find that balance point between between
looking to science for wisdom which I
don't think it has they're two different
words but but also recognizing how much
good and transformative power maybe our
only hope comes from science